Prince Harry has been taken on a flight
in a world war two Spitfire preparing to
mark the 75th anniversary of the Battle
of Britain this summer well the princess
charity the Endeavour fund is supporting
wounded service personnel as they
trained to take part in a special flight
past skies Toby Sadler reports even for
a prince this is a dream come true
flying a loop-de-loop in a Spitfire but
this isn't just a joy ride for Prince
Harry his endeavour fund charity is
paying for two injured servicemen to
learn how to fly this aircraft
Nathan Forster is one of them he was
blown up by an IED in Afghanistan in
2011 in just five months time he'll
pilot the Spitfire in a fly past two
might the 75th anniversary of the Battle
of Britain it's a special aircraft if
it's white saw well known it's such an
iconic the emotions that it brings out
on people again because of its wartime
history but also just what the aircraft
is is such a beautiful aircraft and in
the such a capable aircraft I think
everyone who gets close to one really
really feels what it is it's not it's
more than a piece of machinery did
something special the organizers of the
Spitfire scholarship had initial
concerns about putting disabled pilots
of the controls but in the end they
learned a lesson from the history books
the inspiration for this scholarship
which is the reason Prince Harry was
here was this man when commander Douglas
Barda he lost both his legs before the
war that still went on to become modern
Britain's most successful Spitfire
pilots playing a crucial role in the
Battle of Britain Nathan and fellow
pilot Alan Robinson will get just 10
hours flying time in the Spitfire that
is still twice as much as many pilots
training during the war but the task
ahead is sobering it's a bit tricky
again who would yes is a view a lot of
guys had for the Battle of Britain quite
quite a small cockpit and a lot of lot
of systems going on where Prince Harry
leads many others will follow the Battle
of Britain fly past on the seventeenth
September we'll see more than 35
Spitfires and hurricanes form up over
the south coast as the country remembers
the few who did so much for the many
Toby Sadler Sky News